very very quickly it became quite clear
that this wasn't about george floyd
anymore it was about
this whole host of other issues and it
was actually more a kind of catalyst
for the culture war to explode into the
mainstream which is exactly what
happened and then you have
all major corporations all major
businesses civic institutions
uh schools universities absolutely
everyone in lockstep
over uh basically issues they don't
fully understand
you know i mean when the bbc for
instance um
and sainsbury's as of this week uh
telling their employees to read white
fragility by robin d'angelo which is a
book which is uh
i suppose the most popular example of of
critical race theory that we have at the
moment but it is a very um
very shoddy uh piece of work um which
has been widely discredited and and and
doesn't have the kind of academic
respectability once you move beyond that
sort of niche
of the the kind of post-modern offshoot
such as
uh you know critical race theory
disability studies fact studies gender
studies intersectional feminism
once you go beyond all that people don't
take robin deangelo very seriously
uh businesses do corporations do they
pay her thousands of dollars to go in
and shout at their
white employees and tell them how racist
they all are but it's such a
dangerous divisive backward philosophy
of life it's
it's the idea that you divide us into
oppressed and oppressor
irrespective of our personal
circumstances and you you you
you know it's racist in every way it is
possible to be racist
you know it degrades people of color by
telling them that they're always going
to be victims that they nev they will
never
uh achieve anything that they deserve to
achieve and it's racist against white
people because it tells them that
they're all
oppressive and racist and in particular
robert d'angelo who will claim that if
you deny your complicity in white
supremacy that just proves you're white
supremacist right so this
it's it's absolutely appalling and
abysmal and of course
because she used the phrase and well
people of that ilk use the phrase
anti-racism to describe what they're
doing
if you complain about anti-racism will
make the case that anti-racism is a bad
thing it sounds like you're saying that
you are for
racism and of course the reason for
opposing anti-racism
is if you are concerned about actual
racism that's the problem so
this gets very complicated there's this
whole lexicon you sort of have to
you have to master before you can get
anywhere it also makes people rightly
nervous they understand that you know
most people are are concerned about
the anti-racism in terms of unconscious
bias training implicit bias training
dividing people up i mean sainsbury's
literally created an online safe space
for their black employees i mean how
patronizing is that
um so people are nervous about this but
they don't want to be seen to be opposed
to anti-racism it's a very clever
phrase that they use but what people
have to understand is that anti-racism
is a rehabilitated form of racialized
thinking in other words it is a form of
racism
and if you really care about combating
racism as i do
then you will oppose anti-racism and
you'll go back to
the liberal approach uh the liberal
approach to combating racism and the
reason why that's a good thing is we've
got the past six decades
of progress which prove that it works
and sure
it hasn't achieved a complete utopia
where racism doesn't exist
that will never happen because we live
in a society of human beings and there's
always going to be some
nasty pieces of work amongst us right
but the best the absolute best way
as has been proven by recent history is
the liberal approach is that you would
tackle racism
rigorously whenever it occurs what you
don't do is create this
faith-based philosophy where there are
nebulous power structures that only
people like robert deangelo
are qualified to detect and therefore
you implement policy on that basis in
the government in the arts in education
in the media absolutely everywhere
and then you're solving problems that
may or may not exist on the basis of
this this deity that you've created
that's not the way to go about this
and we know this is the case so people
who do believe in those liberal values
those decent values of equality and
fairness and and looking out for people
and ensuring that people aren't
mistreated in society and discriminated
against those are the people
who need to advance the liberal uh
agenda the social liberalism that has
served us so well
for so long that is now being utterly
demolished before our eyes
you